hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
despite days of negotiations on capitol
hill
members of congress remain divided on a
coronavirus relief deal
west virginia's democratic senator joe
manchin says he thinks lawmakers on both
sides of the aisle should be doing more
to help the american people the senator
shares his insights on the ongoing
debate over coveted 19 stimulus
legislation
the 2020 election and why he says he's
not a washington democrat
like many others in his party and the
pandemic is affecting
virtually every part of the economy but
with social distancing mandates and
nervous passengers
the aviation industry has been hit
particularly hard
former spirit airlines ceo ben beldanza
joins the rundown to discuss
the economic impact of the virus and
what commercial airlines are doing
to keep customers safe plus commentary
from full-time practicing physician
and fox news contributor dr nicole
sapphire
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com i'm greg
jarrett i'm shannon bream i'm steve
ducey and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday august 5th 2020 i'm jessica
rosenthal
as individual states navigate their way
through the pandemic one moderate
democrat says he's focused
less on politics and more on getting his
rural state
internet connections for remote learning
and enough cash to weather the job
losses
you know trump is very very popular in
my state and
i've done everything i can to work with
him i want my president no matter who he
or she may be
i want my president to succeed i've
always said that
i'm dave anthony it's still a tough time
for airlines
as many people avoid travel fearing they
could get sick from just
flying somewhere while you're on that
plane for four to six hours
you're probably safer in terms of
getting virus transmission
than almost anything else you would do
other than just maybe staying at home
and i'm dr nicole sapphire i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
this week the president said in a
sit-down interview that the u.s is doing
well in our fight against the virus
that it's as under control as it can be
and that much of what needed to be done
has been done by states governors whom
he says were given massive amounts of
materials
to do their jobs by his administration
but he also argued the u.s is doing well
when it comes to the number of those
who've died
despite our high death rate he insisted
on comparing the number of deaths to the
number of those who've tested positive
for the virus
rather than the country's population as
a whole tuesday he was asked at the
white house briefing
why he insists our mortality rate is so
low when
per johns hopkins we have the most
deaths compared to our population after
the uk
chile and peru new york had a very tough
time as you know new york new jersey
that area
and when you take them out just as an
example take a look at florida relative
to new york
that's not to say anything wrong with
new york it's just a very tough place
people are close together it's crowded
it's it's not easy
but when you take that out our numbers
are among the lowest and
even with it in i will get back to you
but we have among the lowest numbers
meanwhile federal unemployment benefits
have expired and democratic leadership
is still fighting with the white house
over future virus relief funding and the
president
now says he's okay with mail-in voting
but only in florida
we talked about all of this the virus
the election mail-in ballots
with one of the most moderate democrats
in congress my labels people would know
would be i'm
fiscally responsible and socially
compassionate
and i think most americans with your
democrat republican
have fallen into that category joe
manchin is a u.s senator for west
virginia
and there's just not much of that in the
political arena today
it's almost a tribal mentality to where
you have to
fervently support your tribe no matter
right wrong or indifferent no matter how
radical it might be
and i just won't do that i always said
if i can't
come home to a wonderful west virginia
and explain it i can't vote for it it
doesn't matter whether it's democrat or
republican
issue for against whatever if it doesn't
make any sense whatsoever i'm not going
to support it
and i'm always going to try to be
helpful to the other side so my
republican friends and colleagues i
don't go out and campaign against them
i'm not responsible who they send to
washington to represent them from any
state in the union
my commitment is to work with anybody
that's sent here to make it better for
all of us
uh you know for the entire country and
state and state
let me ask you about the virus um
there's been this accusation that
there's no national
coronavirus plan my understanding is
that most health related issues
fall you know fall under states
jurisdictions
of course there there are national
apparatuses of course we've got hhs and
cdc but
but the many decisions are made more at
a more local level what sort of national
plan
is this administration supposed to have
that would work for the entire country
let's go i'll go back to my childhood
and you're talking in the 50s now okay
polio all my vaccinations were given to
me in school
by the health department can you believe
that
no yeah i mean it was it was
very functional very very uh effective
now that wasn't local from the
standpoint other than the local people
who were administering it
but it was a national movement as far as
polio vaccination
and and all different types of things
that we were
protected by growing up and it was just
a different time and
to say now we don't have a
responsibility national institute of
health cdc
all of them basically we should stay
ahead of all this we should have
there's there should be a cadre and
there always has been a cadre of
scientists
that were scoping and scouring the world
finding out
where we could be vulnerable
i never could figure out why the
president didn't immediately didn't
immediately no matter what
no matter what the sins of the past has
been and whoever wants to blame whoever
previous administrations or this
administration once we have it we know
what's coming at us
then you should use the defense
protection
act basically production act defense
production act to put
every force you have in mo and movement
in motion so that people don't be held
honorable so we should have
testing available ppe and it shouldn't
be profiteering either
anyone who has the ability to
manufacture what's needed
to protect american citizens must be
called to arms and do it
well i believe that was a great great
thing that we missed
what is going on with the coronavirus
relief future relief bill
uh it seems like things are still kind
of far apart but but there's still
but there's movement the leadership is
talking is it just over the
amount it sounds like the white house is
you know treasury secretary mnuchin
is stuck on this one trillion number
democrats want more is that what it
comes down to just the amount
well i think if you look at the
democrats right now from the house side
they said we've passed a bill
so we've done our job and it's a very
large 3 trillion dollar bill
i personally don't support that that
amount that they're putting towards
different areas not saying that we don't
have a need but you can't cure
all the social needs within a
pandemic bill or health crisis bill
first of all you should take care of the
health crisis and i've said this
no it's not one hospital definitely not
one rural hospital should ever close
during a pandemic
there shouldn't be one health care
provider that's not able to be in
business to take care of people in need
so let's put the money where it's needed
this is a health care crisis what are we
doing
are we doing enough to protect people
are we doing enough to test people
you're asking people to go back into
a normal life or go back to work go back
to school
well you know we know the children can
carry be asymptomatic and carry it
so now we're asking teachers who might
have vulnerable parents at home or
vulnerable members of their family
they're going to be concerned they want
to make sure that they're protected they
want to make sure
that this kid's coming to school are
basically not infected
i understand all that and on top of that
you want to add insult to injury
they're saying well we're going to allow
distant learning that's
wonderful if you live in the halls in
the mountains of west virginia
don't you have to have connectivity
don't you have to have high-speed
broadband connectivity
how in the heck do you believe these
people can function
in a coveted crisis for the next five or
six months until we get a vaccine
and have no internet tell me that
tell me how a patient an elderly patient
who can't leave their home should not
leave their home
is going to get telehealth when they
have no connectivity
are you working on are you working on
that yes we are trying to on the
internet
i i have bill on that it's called
basically and i've spoke to
mnuchin i think we're going to get it
and you know he was very
receptive i said steve how in the world
do you expect us to navigate in rural
america rural appalachia
when people have no connectivity that
you're determined that they should have
in order to have the services they need
he says finances we need hot spots
if nothing else i said at least we can
have hot spots available to citizens
that live in remote areas to go to the
library and take it like you would check
out a book
and be able to have some connectivity my
critique
constructive criticism critique of of
mitch mcconnell
mitch we've had two to three months
you've never put a working group
together a bipartisan working group
we've asked for this so we have to do it
in the back of the halls and talk to
each other what's going on
do you agree with this do you agree with
that what can you live with manchester
says he was all for making people whole
who lost their jobs or businesses
but that 600 additional dollars a week
for some west virginians
was more than they had been making and
so they weren't super excited to go back
to work
okay here's the employer says okay now
we're starting to reopen
and i can't be get people to come back
to work well if the employer by right
would say i'm going to turn you in to
unemployment compensation office in my
state or my locality or my area
that you've been offered a full-time job
to come back to and you won't come back
to it you'll lose your unemployment
benefits
but they didn't want to do that they
didn't want to cause all the problems
and hard feelings that would come
they said well i just have to live with
it to july 31st
now the bill comes along expanding that
to the end of the year
and they're saying we can't live with
that so what do you do there's got to be
a pathway for it
that's all and you got to sit down and
be reasonable about this
it sounds like you're asking for some
nuance um
let me ask you before i let go about the
election
uh because there there seems to be a
debate over debates
um some in the in the media are calling
for
uh no debates uh saying you know they
serve no purpose
in in the president's case they're
they're saying you know one of the
articles says it just allows him to put
on this
this show um but but is it
really about that or is there a concern
that a debate
performance could make the former vice
president joe biden
look bad or weak or not as sharp as
president trump
no i don't i don't think that at all
i've known joe biden for quite some time
joe biden just a good quality human
being he's got a heart and a soul
truly has a heart and a soul he's been
through some difficult times and
some challenges and a lot of things
thrown at him and all that but i can
tell you when it comes time
uh he's always been there he always
wants to help he always wants to be
involved he's just been
very compassionate i've always found
that and i think right now that country
needs a heart and soul
and needs someone understands the pain
that people go through
so it sounds like you're saying we
should have the debates i've always
i mean i think the people deserve to see
both up side by side and make their
decision
even though people seem to be already
made it so you know trump is very
very popular in my state and very much
supported
i've done everything i can to work with
him i want
my president no matter who he or she may
be i want my president to succeed i've
always said that
and whoever that president is always
always work to help them succeed
i truly will but i just believe that the
change is needed right now for the sake
of our country
finally senator um you are involved in
the mail-in ballot issue i know
president trump has said that he might
even sign an executive order
uh we don't have any details on that yet
but um
he expressed some frustration with
nevada's new bill that's
going to give every registered voter a
mail-in ballot he tweeted that it's
um like stealing the election and and
furthermore that the post office
won't be able to really handle this
influx of ballots
um the post office has said it it
believes you know that the post
master general said they believe they
can handle you know everything but
we we also understand there may be some
service cuts and and closures you're
you're involved in this you're concerned
about this
oh my goodness the first thing they did
i mean a week or two ago i think
at least a week ago we had post offices
in west virginia posting notices they'd
be closed
they were closing i said where is this
coming from
wrote a letter immediately and they
retracted that and said they're going to
review process this and that
i mean it's awful this this person just
a joy is absolutely i think
uh committed to closing uh post offices
and
making them uh private uh so i have a
bill called the post act
okay let's protect our services today
it's very i mean for the sake of
democracy and it's acre
for many many millions of americans
that's the lifeline they have
their medicine comes through the postal
services these are people that live in
rural areas that don't
have internet connectivity so the post
office is their lifeline
and it has always been our connectivity
to the freedoms that we enjoy and the
democracy that we have and i just cannot
believe
that a person is not committed to making
this work
we can't even get a refer a phone call
returned from dejoy
and this person put in this purely
political
partisanship he put him in a position
that
the man has been flagrantly opposed to
the uh
postal service and so your your bill
would
just stop what you're doing at least
during the pandemic you cannot close any
post offices during that and that was
pretty
pretty simple you cannot do it
senator manchin thank you so much for
your time thank you for having me i
enjoyed it very much
[Music]
this is dr nicole sapphire with your fox
news commentary coming up
are you ready to travel in this corona
crisis
american delta and united are all adding
more international flights
at a time when more people are traveling
on sunday the tsa
reported the number of passengers who
went through airport checkpoints was
nearly 800
000 that is the most of any day in this
entire pandemic
and up from a low back on april 14th of
just 87
000. however the industry is still far
from recovering
that 800 000 number on sunday was less
than a third
of what it was august 2nd a year ago
and as the coronavirus surged across the
u.s lately
ticket sales were reportedly down 79
percent last week versus the same period
in 2019
i would say the two biggest words
relating to the industry right now are
uncertainty and
competence ben baldanza is the former
ceo for spirit airlines
meaning uncertainty about what the world
is going to be going forward as it
relates to this virus
and demand for the industry and
confidence which is what is
needed for the industry to engender in
customers
to feel safe flying again so airlines
are
you know have put in sort of multiple
layers of safety things from what they
do in the airport
to the way the air flows on the airplane
to the way they're cleaning
um about half the airlines are keeping
more space in the airplane
plane by blocking seats not all airlines
are doing that some are
but the whole game now has tried to make
customers
recognize that they can fly and be safe
or at least as safe in anything else
they would go do
in this pandemic world right now now i
know that
social distancing is very very hard to
do on an airplane
i mean you the whole point you have to
pack as many seats in as you can on an
airplane right in order to
make money in the industry so when you
talked about
not having some seats available like the
middle seat which some airlines are
doing
how difficult is it to make any money as
an airline when you don't sell those
seats
well in the short term it can work in
the following ways
if you think about it in economic terms
the airplanes are already
paid for right they're not getting
they're not able to not pay for the
airplanes right now
the people in the airline industry at
least until the end of september
are being paid through the cares act um
and that was you know a 25 billion
dollar grant from the government
to keep airline employment up basically
if that not happened a lot of people
would have been laid off or furloughed
and they would have gone on unemployment
roles so the government would have paid
that way
by keeping those people employed it
allowed them to stay trained to stay
current in their job
so as capacity could come back they were
there ready to fly those flights
so the people are being paid now the
airplanes are paid for and fuel prices
are pretty cheap
so because of that those are the three
biggest costs an airline has
fuel labor and uh and planes
and that they can make they can make
positive cash
with only maybe 20 or 30 people on the
plane there have already been talks of
tens of thousands of potential furloughs
looming
if congress doesn't act and so far
they're having a hard time with any kind
of stimulus in congress at the moment
what happens in october if they don't
get any more money
airlines have been have been encouraging
early outs or um leave without pay
for people to voluntarily say i'll step
out for a few more months
some people might say you know i'd
rather not be in the airplane right now
and so
maybe i'll take a few months off and can
deal without the pay
and what they're trying to do is
minimize the number of people who would
actually have to be furloughed or laid
off
on at that point but the fact is the
industry will need fewer people
needs fewer people today and if they're
not being paid they will have to let
those people go
that's why i think it's so important
that
congress you know act appropriately
to support business and i think a re-up
of the cares money
as it relates to airline employees makes
a lot of sense
even with nobody sitting in the middle
seat next to me and there's somebody
you know in the aisle seat maybe a
couple feet over and i got somebody
behind me and i got somebody in front of
me and i'm sitting on a flight for four
to six hours breathing the same air
that's what people think anyway that's
the concern a lot of people have is
they're sitting there for
hours and hours breathing the same air
tell me how
airlines fix that how how does an
airline
scrub the air in a plane
well they've what the airlines have to
do is do a better job of fixing that
narrative because the reality is you're
not sitting there for four to six hours
breathing the same air
the air in the airplane is recirculated
every three to five minutes
with fresh air from the outside so
basically every five minutes you're
breathing new fresh air
because the air sucked in through the
engines comes in from the top of the
airplane and vertically flows
down so imagine if you and i are sitting
in a restaurant
and we're sitting maybe 20 30 feet apart
and i cough
the airflow in that restaurant which is
horizontal will
essentially deliver my cough droplets to
you right so it's a yeah that's a
somewhat risky situation
if we're sitting on the same plane and
i'm sitting in front or behind you and i
cough well first of all we'll both be
wearing masks if we're on the airplane
that's required now so i'm
unless you can't wear a mask the entire
time right that's right
but secondly i'll have the your seat
back in front of me if i'm behind you
right so i'll cough into that
and the last thing is the airflow in the
plane will actually take my droplets and
push them down
to the floor it will not carry them
forward to you because it's vertical
so airlines i think need to do a better
job of explaining the way air really
moves on the airplane
and how it is refreshed regularly
throughout the flight
so while you're on that plane for four
to six hours
you're probably safer in terms of
getting virus transmission
than almost anything else you would do
other than just maybe staying at home
i mean so in a movie theater which a lot
of people aren't going in movie theaters
you mentioned restaurants
that's the air in a plane you're saying
is circulated much more than a lot of
other indoor places we go
yeah office office um office buildings
grocery stores restaurants yes buildings
that we
still will go to today you know but
while keeping our physical distance
that's right
what about cleaning on the airplane i
just saw a story that southwest
is not going to do the seat belts
anymore in between flights they'll do
them
you know at the end of the day but in
between flights they won't clean the
seat belts or the armrests but they will
do the trade tables i guess the
bathrooms as well
what does an airline have to do do you
think between flights
i think they should clean as best as
they can i think they should
also encourage people to bring their own
maybe a disinfectant wipe
and you can control the actual space
you're in
i've been fine the last few months and i
brought a wipe on board and just wiped
down my armrest and my seat and the
little knobs above that you pulled the
air out and i just felt better about it
i didn't know that i needed to do that
i didn't think they were dirty i don't
know that the airlines hadn't cleaned
those surfaces
those same services 15 minutes earlier
but i said i can control where i sit at
least
and take ownership of that um you may
have seen that jet blue just announced
that a partnership with honeywell
where um in the evenings at two of their
biggest uh
airports they're gonna be using this
robot that puts uv
light through the whole airplane um it's
it's an interesting thing
though we'll see if it works and
basically the robot will go up and down
the aisle and it'll disinfect all the
all the parts of the airplane now that's
not something they could do between
every flight
but if the airplane is starting the day
fully disinfected
cleaned throughout the day then
disaffected at the end of the day
that hopefully will sort of send the
message about
the airplane can be a clean place to be
for the couple hours you're there
flight attendants have a tougher job now
because
you know if someone doesn't want to wear
a mask or doesn't have it on the whole
time
they have to attempt to sort of be like
police in the air a little bit on that
and
it's got to be a really difficult task
i totally agree with you flight
attendants jobs are difficult in any
environment
but then sort of having to be police on
mask is something that
they really shouldn't be in that
position the airlines require it
you can't board the plane without the
mask so if someone decides to make their
political statement on board and say i'm
not going to wear the mask
i think the right thing for the flight
attendants to do is politely ask them to
put it on and if they don't put it on
then go tell the captain
and most airlines today are being more
aggressive
about banning customers who behave that
way you saw
just a week ago or so that delta
airlines
returned a flight to the gate when two
customers wouldn't put their mass on the
flight attendants told the company said
well we'll go back to the gate and take
those people off
and when there's a consequence to not
wearing your mask
such as you won't be able to fly on that
airline anymore or you're not going to
even take the trip that you thought you
were going to take
then hopefully people will behave do you
think any airlines
that are flying now will no longer be
flying go out of business because of
this
well i think that um you know you've
already seen
some airlines in parts of the world file
for bankruptcy protection
you've seen a couple go out of business
the last number i saw was that over 900
airplanes around the world that were
flying before covet have now been
retired and rejected so 900 airplanes
are not coming back
that were there so you're already
starting to see that
i think within the united states the
airlines are generally financially
pretty strong
from a history of eight to ten years of
good profitability and generally
sound cash management so i think that
airlines in the us
are doing the right things around
managing their cash getting good sources
of liquidity
flying the amount of capacity that can
be that can generate more cash
and and reducing you know um
costs that aren't needed to spend right
now so
unless this unless the um the demand
shortfall lasts you know years and years
and years
longer than people expect um i think the
us airlines are probably in
shape to to not have to file bankruptcy
or go out of business
the biggest risk um is with the carriers
who are
very dependent on long-haul travel
that's because i believe long-haul
travel has a higher hurdle
to recover then short haul travel even
after you or i
may be comfortable saying okay i'm
willing to fly a two-hour flight to new
york or
dallas or something like that that
doesn't mean that we want to be on a
plane for 14 hours
connecting dubai and fly another eight
hours right
and so um so i think the long haul
travel is
is an issue i think the the governmental
rules around quarantines
keep changing there you certainly don't
want to fly someplace and then have to
stay in a hotel for 14 days
or while you're there find out that when
you come back to the u.s you're going to
have to
quarantine for 14 days so that adds
another risk to the long-haul travel
and the airplanes involved in those
flights are the most expensive to buy
and the most expensive to fly
in the industry so for all those reasons
airlines
like a delta united american that fly
those kinds of planes for part of their
service
or an airline like emirates or singapore
where most of their services like that
are going to have the biggest challenge
here ben baldanza former ceo for spirit
airlines current ceo for democr thanks
so much for joining us
thank you so much for a great
[Music]
conversation
it's the perino and stirewalt i'll tell
you what podcast dana perino of the five
and fox news political editor chris
stirewalt dissect the ins and outs of
national politics
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
dr
nicole sapphire what's on your mind
nearly six months after covet 19 began
to ravage our communities
there remain three constants the threat
of the pandemic reigns
prevalent frontline health responders
and other essential workers continue
tirelessly
and politicians are finding ways to
exploit the crisis to benefit special
interest groups
over the last few months hundreds of u.s
healthcare workers have already died
from covid19
nonetheless nurses doctors and many
other medical personnel continue their
efforts while acknowledging the risk
that accompanies their jobs
meanwhile on capitol hill there is a
renewed effort to include legislation in
any
new covid19 relief bill that would show
politicians sincere appreciation for
doctors and other service providers
by essentially cutting their pay
historically there has been a push by
members of congress to
rate set for out-of-network coverage
which effectively punishes doctors in a
misguided attempt to solve for what
some call surprise medical billing the
goal is laudable and one that we can all
support
patients should not be the one stuck in
the middle of billing disputes
and no patient should go bankrupt for
emergency medical procedures
but the balance occurs when a patient
receives a bill for the difference
between the cost
of the medical service and what their
health insurance is
willing to pay so really it should be
called
surprise insurance denial rather than
surprise medical billing
what we continue to see are insurance
companies playing their usual
games in order to either squeeze
patients or health care providers by not
covering the cost of services provided
turning to government rate setting is
akin to putting money
back in the pockets of the goliath
health insurance companies
rather than paying the doctors and other
personnel for services rendered
they do this by keeping reimbursements
rates so
low that doctors and other medical
service providers are
forced to further consolidate or stop
taking insurance altogether
the impact of government rate setting
will be felt the most in rural areas of
the country where quality
medical care is scarce to begin with
faced with
budget constraints providers will need
to cut services
hospitals will cost shift and even air
ambulances which are particularly
critical in rural america will need to
close air bases
americans cannot be faced with a care
shortage crisis right now
if covid19 has taught us anything it is
the role that high quality healthcare
plays in keeping this country safe
too many regions in our country are
already feeling the effects of hospital
closures in their community from
reimbursement cuts
that will only be exacerbated if the
medical community is hurt financially
because of the surprise insurance denial
legislation that's currently being
discussed
meanwhile there are two groups that
benefit greatly by
these legislations health insurers and
the politicians
who receive the industry's very generous
contributions
if the out of network legislation goes
through the insurance companies will be
popping a cork with their washington dc
allies as politicians are also
beneficiaries
when insurance companies profit while
doctors nurses hospital staff and emts
continue to descend on the hardest hit
areas across the u.s
we now see what the health insurance are
up to
they dispatch their well-paid army of
lobbyists to infiltrate washington dc
and work with their pawns in congress to
concoct a scheme
a scheme that will inflict direct
consequences on our frontline heroes
congress and the white house should be
finding ways to protect our health
responders
as covid19 continues to demand their
resources
not empowering health insurers to
continue their deceitful and destructive
practice of surprise insurance denial
this is dr nicole sapphire i'm a fox
news contributor and author of the
best-selling book make america healthy
again
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa
just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it
on demand love fox news click the
subscribe button to get more of the news
and opinion you trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes